welcome to this video playing soon uber
and now it's not going for the Kings
Indian again he likes to play the Kings
Indian usually so we get some kind of
symmetrical English I guess maybe he's
not taking playing d6 no and he sings
here do you succeed looks utterly wrong
yeah okay so let's see how he is going
to keep this position playable yeah with
the King running around all over the
place so Knight g5 comes into
consideration Knight d5 also looks good
a 95 is probably good and now I know
Knight g5 looks like normal move but
maybe we have something else and
actually five if I take then my in this
pawn structure is pretty bad but might
still be playable but okay I threaten
actually to take and play Bishop h3
which would be that would be really
terrible for black
yeah this is a serious idea
no don't quite know what black supposed
to play him looks very uncomfortable he
encourages me to take that's crazy
how are you not losing the house here
yeah so here I can probably just take
right take the night the ship takes t7
and then like Bishop f4 that's going to
that's not going to work for black I can
also take a 7 with check also pretty bad
yeah come on yeah that that you cannot
survive yeah I mean particularly not
that no that's a bit too bad
yeah the getting the King onto the 8 is
a little bit a little bit much and it's
it's not very very necessary you can
just take on default cause him what you
can do is you can react with d6 if you
have castle so you could think about
canceling if you absolutely want to not
take into your play D 6 because here the
capture you can actually retake with the
rook so yeah this is this is just bad
for black I mean quite clearly yeah this
and now
yeah Knight g5 immediately is given by
the engine I kind of suspected that this
is strong but I didn't I wasn't entirely
sure he FP 3 and I wasn't sure about
that diagonal the engine gives me an
advantage but mm-hmm
you know that that is not a bad move I
don't think ya know 95 mm mm age 6 the
engine doesn't find something better
either and here this is this is really
bad Knight takes d5 is a relatively best
move why can I not take on D 56 again I
thought this one but this isn't even
that great according to the comp which
is 0.6 it's it's good of course but okay
I mean this I can just take yeah yeah 97
is a bit tougher but then white has 97 I
was actually thinking this move
threatening mate that's pretty nice
ice-cold root f8 I didn't count
that well and then bishops his seven
that's a strange move that I would
wouldn't have played and we can look at
faith as a good phony oh okay
so he should have tried that but Knight
is setting is given by the calm as being
very strong and joy 95 something like
that not going to work and he avoids
disastrous see takes a stronger even our
God
my kitty Sam now you can and you cannot
stop the point that's very neat that's
very neat the engine has some kind of
made already
yeah check check check
no and so on yeah you cannot play with
the King in the center there justice is
too too problematic okay guys thanks for
watching